traitez pas si vous m'entendez je ne
sais pas si vous me recevait
actuellement nous sommes
sur un plateau oui mais on
à une embrouille au mondial
alors je vous le dis a priori on est
victime d'une attaque
de qui ça craint une attaque de
catégorie b
c'est-à-dire une attaque ce qu'on
appelle si bergues la
cyberattaque
cyber attaques on veut dire il faut
qu'on parle en code c'est à dire que
l'attaqué vient de chez bear non c'est
le gars n'ont alors je vous dis france
24 a sauté oui petit chat fautif haye a
sauté oui la culotte de déneigement
oui ils se font attaquer vraiment au
point au centre médical
du pays e
ça chez nous voilà donc qu'à moi
passée à huy
chose qu'on doit pas dire donc voilà
pour l'instant vous m'entendez
tout est revenue mais nous travaillons
et nous faisons cette émission dans la
peur
nourdine le producteur de l'émission qui
suit l'émission tout comme vous tous
comme moi est toujours sur le vraiment
sur le fil du rasoir c est la pointe de
l'actu bien de dire dans mon oreille
france 24 a sauté aussi on l'a dit
nordine toujours tout cela pour croyez
toujours qu'il va me dire un truc hyper
important dans l'oreillette et le dis en
fait jamais elle arrivait jamais donc on
les aime beaucoup
mais la lnd 1h40 être sachez que ça peut
souhaiter à tout moment je le dis aux
téléspectateurs
si ça ressorte une fois on sera dans
l'obligation d'arrêter l'émission
au bout de 45 minutes quand même nom en
vente en plateau
[Applaudissements]
ces pays pouvaient être payés je vous le
dis ça me fait énormément de peine à ce
que l'émission était très bien ouais
vous je sais que vous n'avez rien à dire
social mais l'émission était top alors
on va décider à main levée que fait-on
ou bien on prend le risque de faire
l'émission et qu'à tout moment ça saute
et qu'on se retrouve
ou bien on se dit on stop on arrête les
frais leur propre et chacun rentre chez
soi et les moutons seront bien gardées
c'est la mort dans l'âme que nous devons
arrêter cette émission si et seulement
si elle si ceux qui ont fait une
première
qui est seulement si il y à une autre
coupure
bien s'il
ya une personne impliquée qui vient de
voilà qu'il vient de tomber voilà je ne
sais pas s'il est tombé pour elle c'est
parce que l'eau du 3 mai à une personne
est tombée les gains de subir une cyber
attaque également
mais cyber là c'est le chien enfin